the best it's lovely to see you here at
collector mania everyone enjoyed you so
much we saw you in the five ish doctors
as well see it for the 50th anniversary
what was it like taking part in that it
was a hoot it was great fun we we
started making it at the beginning of
the year in Australia and then it kind
of it was very amateurish thing with you
know handheld camera owned by Peter and
then suddenly the BBC got a bit involved
it became semi-professional what we just
used to win a roo and working grabbed
time I one point I had to give up
breakfast in Paris to race back because
Paul was only free that morning and I
think about comparison film with him you
know it's all that kind of thing going
on but at the same time it's just a hoot
a great fun and of course a fantastic
cast of characters well and actors what
was it like working with those guys
again
well I mean you know it's John Barbera
my name is that was delightful outing
John Barrowman
you know he's not gay really he's got a
family with children and then I'm the
various others and what was also
delightful was asked I asked Peter
Jackson when I was filming in New
Zealand that and in june/july last year
if he would do that little bit and he
did and he got Ian involved I didn't ask
him but Peter said inor do it he'll do
it so that was good it was great
watching it too seen Shaun in it you
know Sean Pertwee and the various other
people that popped up and Russell T
Davies it was hilarious at the end
wasn't it
and all I mean it's Peter Jack Peter
Davidson is the kind of the guy behind
it that he and his daughter you know
Paul David Tennant's wife my sad
daughter granddaughter other what
relationships to all the doctors but
anyway you know who I mean Victoria this
is Georgia it's Georgia with charger yet
delightful lovely Georgia where she
mentioned there's a little crossover
wasn't there with the hobbits and the
doctor and of course I'm sure if you
have been asking you about The Hobbit as
well today they love you in that as
radagast I mean what was it like joining
that world and getting fitted out for
the part of radagast well it's a great
adventure huge adventure taken nearly
three years we going back and forward to
New Zealand and Australia and traveling
all over the world I'm getting fitted
out was you know easy the costume was
easy to put on take off the makeup was a
bit longer took an hour and a half I
mean the bird poo was you know well
someone had to do it it's a pulley job
but someone had to do it I mean did you
have any kind of radagast or wizard
equivalent of the dwarf camp that the
drawers went on no no no I didn't I was
lucky in that way I didn't have to run
about although everything quite fun I
mean I think they had a good time and
doing all that no I just I arrived you
know they put the bird poop on me and
sent me on to the set what do you find
was the most challenging thing that you
shot over the course of the three movie
this year I think the scene where I save
sebastian is it Sebastian's life yeah
the Hedgehog's life I mean that was very
challenging because I was the only one
there and therefore they just we will
film for 12 hours and the set was
delightful but it was also incredibly
hot and they had to pump cold air in you
know as well and the the the floor was
higgledy-piggledy and so yeah you kind
of twist your ankle running around it
was very very very very yeah kind of
demanding but great I mean I also the
same time it was great to be able to do
that you know have that privilege of
being on a big huge screen with just me
and an upstaging hedgehog and what are
you most looking forward to about the
upcoming movie which is recently been
retitled hasn't it - the Battle of the
five armies well yes I mean I think
everybody knows if they've read the book
that there is a Battle of five armies
well I'm looking forward to see if I'm
in it
recently I'm Viggo Mortensen who of
course was in the Lord of the Rings
trilogy and talked about working with
Peter Jackson and he said that when he
filmed those Lord of the Rings films
that the second and third film weren't
quite as organized as people thought
they might even at a time there was a
lot of reshoots and he felt it was a
little bit of a mess I mean what did you
how did you find it working with Peter
Jackson's obviously we've got one book
here that's been expanded into three
films I found it great I mean I really
like Peter I mean I got to know I'm
obviously working on it and he's a
really down-to-earth you know good bloke
um hey and know everything seems to work
very smoothly as far as I can my
experience really although we were only
filming two films up until the last week
and then something he said I think we're
going to make it into three so come back
next year and do some more you know well
okay I I wasn't at all disappointed to
go back again for a third year no I
enjoyed working with him a lot really
and finally you've got to welcome a new
doctor onto the screen very shortly what
are you looking forward to seeing about
Peter Capaldi's doctor well it's great
to go back to a more mature doctor I
think that's in that'd be interesting
just for tale telling really he'll have
a different kind of hue and color on it
because of his being or he's being older
but and he's a great actor and so you
know there's no reason why he won't be a
great doctor
you